[موسيقى]
كنت قلقانه منها اللغه الصعيدي بس معنا
مصحح لغه واستاذ عبد النبي بصراحه طمنا
كلنا كلنا يمكن الناس كتير كانت قلقانه
لان في ناس اشتغلت صعيدي قبل كده طبعا
جمال سليمان اشتغل قبل كده
بس احنا معظم الناس ما اشتغلناش الحقيقه
فكنا قلقانين بس هو طمنا بصراحه وكان
بيشتغل معنا طول الوقت
واتعلمنا كتير يمكن تعبنا في الاول اكتر
حاجه وبعد كده الامور بقت اسهل اول عمل
يجمعك مع زوجك هشام لا اشتغلنا مع بعض
فلوس قليله لسه هينزل على ام بي سي
بس هنا يعني تقريبا
مش شغالين مع بعض
بس بتبقوا ما فيش مشاهد بتجمعكم لكن في
مشهد واحد بس لكن هي الخطين مختلفين خالص
هو بيتين مختلفين بيت حسن ابو عصايه وبيت
عبد الجبار قولي لي بقى يعني كانيلي وهشام
عشان تشتغلوا في لوكيشن واحد وتيجوا
المشوار المرهق ده كل يوم
قربكم من بعض بعادكم عن بعض جدا لان احنا
بنشتغل في اوقات غير كل واحد بيشتغل في
اوقات غير التاني
وهو بيبقى ليه ايام وانا لي ايام انا
ساعات بيبقى عندي اجازه وهو بيشتغل والعكس
صحيح همم شغلانه مرهقه جدا يعني بجد طب
هاتي تابعتي اداءه كان لك كان ليكي اي
ملاحظات على اداءه ولا كنت بتبعدي قلتي لا
انا مش مليش دعوه يعني بصي انا دايما يعني
لو يعني انا وهو بنتفرج مع بعض
يعني مش انا اللي اقول الكومنت بصراحه
يعني عنده مخرج يقول لكم طب هو بيسالك
يقول لك ايه رايك
سالني يعني اه بقول له حقيقي وهو عامل دور
حلو جدا وهو دور صعب دوره من الشخصيه اللي
هي متعلمه وبعد كده بيدخل
مع والده اللي هو حسن ابو عصايه برضو
العادات والتقاليد
شخصيه مركبه شخصيه صعبه
وكمان خلي بالك صعيدي برضو اول مره
عاش في امريكا عشان
بيبقى السويتش ده صعب بس انا شايفه ان
بصراحه كل الناس يعني استاذ عبد النبي عمل
شغل عالي ههه اخر يوم اه والله اخر يوم
ومش مصدقين احنا يعني المنطقه الاجواء
كانت صعبه جدا بس انا حاسس الناس كلها
بتتكلم دلوقتي وبتقول ان يعني حيوحشنا
المكان يعني هيوحشنا المكان مع ان الدنيا
فيها فئران وبتاع بس
الصحراء بس احنا مبسوطين ان انتم يعني
قدرتوا توصلوا لحد هنا
يعني دي حاجه يعني داخله مش سهله وفي
دخلتين لو دخلتي من الناحيه تغرزي برافو
عليكم الحمد لله
يا
حبيبتي
عايزه اقول لك ان ممثل هايل وممتاز وعنده
كاريزما تحفه بعيد عن اي حد بقى عشان ما
ناخدش حق الناس استاذه فريده انت كنت انت
ام شديده قوي لا لا
صعيديه ولكن يعني بينت ان يعني عشان انا
سعوديه يعني ما عنديش لذيذه
مش شديده يعني
دورك دورك شديد طب وهشام انت
نور رومانسي الاستاذ
طيب ماشي
حروف يا حبيبه قلبي الف مبروك كل سنه
وانتم طيبين يا حبايبي مبروك
يا حبيبه قلبي يا حبيبتي ازاي بتقيم عملك
مع نيللي مع مراتك يعني انتم انا بقول لها
هل ده قربكم من بعض انتوا بعدتوا عن بعض
انتوا بتنزلوا تيجوا المشوار الصعب ده
يوميا
قربته بعدته فيه تنافسي يعني انتم هشرح لك
هو هو الواحد بيتهيالي الموقف اللي احنا
فيه ده يعرفك يعني لو اي اثنين متجوزين
عايزين يعرفوا بيحبوا بعض ولا لا ده
يشتغلوا مع بعض يعني لان انت لو ما بتحبش
البني ادم اللي معاك ده تزعل منه انت
بتشوفه كل يوم في الشغل وتشوفه هنا
وبتشوفه هنا فالحمد لله يعني ده ثاني ثالث
اختبار وبالتالي ان احنا يعني انا ببقى
مبسوط لما بشوفها
يعني يا حبيبتي يعني ربنا يخليكم لبعض
بيبقى في ملاحظات منها ليك او انت وبتقول
لها على ملاحظاتك على دورها ولا انتم
سايبين ده للمخرج لا احنا احنا بنتكلم في
في حدود اللي ينفع نتكلم فيه يعني هي هي
عبقريه في نوع من في نوع من البني ادمين
بيبقى عندهم نوع معين من من الذكاء وبتبقى
عبقري بطريقه كده ان انت ما بتعرفش تقول
للناس تعمل ايه انت بس اللي بتعرف تعملها
انت مش مدرس انت عبقري يعني رقم واحد في
العالم في اي حاجه او احسن واحد في اي
حاجه مش بالضروره يكون هو ده اللي بيعرف
يشرحها ولكن هي بتبقى عنده تبقى رباني
بتبقى موجوده هي عندها حاجه رباني يعني
انا بيتهيالي قبل ما تبدا المسلسل الصعيدي
انا كنت شاكك في الصعيدي بتاع بنسبه 80%
بتاعها هي وبتاع انا كنت احنا ما كناش
خايفين عليا كنا خايفين عليها اول ما
الكاميرا قالت اكشن بتتحول بتتحول عظيمه
يعني ايه عظيمه بصراحه يعني مصدقه في جامد
جدا وهي ما بتصدقش في حد كتير فدي برضه من
الحاجات الحظ
والله الحب يعني عشان الحب قصدي ههه
عايزاك على طول وخلي بالك اصل هي لو هي
يعني هتعملها حبا فيا هتبقى الفتره صغيره
وهتضرب في وشنا احنا الاتنين في وقت معين
بنقعد لوحات تاني يوم يعني احنا الحد
الادنى ليوم العمل التصوير يعني الحد
الادنى الادنى 12 سنه
تعذبت عشان اوصل انتم متعذبين بقى لكم قد
ايه
في الجميل ايوه احنا ماشي بنتكلم كنا
بنسجل اغنيه دلوقتي على التيك توك بالصعيد
بسم الله انا بهزر انا وريم سميره
نعمل اغنيه مال برده يعني القاعده هنعمل
ايه طيب هنعمل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات